The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So last time you started
kinetics which is a completely
different topic from
thermodynamics.
They're related and we'll see a
relationship at some point.
And you did first
order kinetics.
And today we're going to move
on and go ahead and do more
complicated kinetics and
hopefully get to some
interesting stuff in
a couple lectures.
Right now we just have to do
the review of stuff that
you've probably seen before.
And so we're going to
go reasonably fast.
So you saw first order
reactions.
Today we're going to do second
order reactions.
At least begin with second
Second order kinetics.
Of the form, and then
there are two kinds.
There's first order, rather,
second order, in one reactant
of the form A goes
to products.
And then you have first order
in two reactants first order
in two reactants.
So I'll have the form A plus
B goes of products.
Where that's first order in A
and first order in B, and this
is second order in A. So you can
think of this as A plus A
goes to products if you want.
And there's some rate
constant k,
associated with this reaction.
And we do the rate analysis.
We write the rate
of this process.
Minus dA/dt.
And for the purpose of writing
on the board, and you might
want to do this also in
your homework, when
you're tired of writing.
I'm going to skip
the brackets.
The little brackets that we
usually put for concentration.
I'm going to skip those, because
it's just too much
work to write them.
And you can understand that A
is a concentration of A. So
this is equal to k A squared.
Second order on A. And the units
for k, it's important to
keep track of your units, at the
end of the calculations,
often you want to make sure
your units work out.
So the units for k are going
to be of this, A is
in moles per liter.
The units for k, you're going
to have to be able to match
the units on this side here.
So the units for k are going to
be liters squared per mole
squared per second.
To make the units match.
Then you integrate this, on both
sides, from zero to t, or
from A0, the initial rate, to A.
Or from zero to t and this
doesn't go like this.
So integrate with A0 to A.
You've got dA over A squared,
you put all the A's on one side,
all the t's on the other
side, from zero to t dt with a
minus k on this side here.
And then you get your rate
equation, integrated rate
equation for this.
Which gives you one over A is
equal to kt plus one over A0.
So this gives you A as
a function of time.
And this is a convenient way
to write it, because it's
linear in time.
So you always try to get things
to be linear in time.
Because then you can plot
them as a straight line.
Plot on this axis here you plot
one over A. on this axis
here you plot t as a
function of time.
And then you get a straight
line where the slope is k.
Gives you the rate, and the
intercept is one over A0.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: k is moles per liter
squared per second.
You're right, liters per
mole per second, yes.
That is correct. because
it has to work.
Otherwise it doesn't work.
So I need to turn on my brain.
OK, think.
Liters per mole per second.
Thank you.
And the other thing that you
want to know is the half-life.
What is the half-life.
So you set 2 A0.
So A0 over two, you look for the
time where you get to A0
over two, so you put A0
over two in here.
And that's going to be equal
to k times t 1/2
plus one over A0.
So you solve for the half-life
and you get a half-life
of one over k A0.
So the half-life is inversely
proportional to the amount of
stuff you started out with.
Unlike the first order reaction,
where the half-life
was independent of the amount
that you started out with.
So this was the easy one.
The next one is a little
bit more complicated.
Which is when your first order
in each of two reactants.
Then your rate, your
differential rate equation,
looks like this.
Because the k times A times B,
and now you don't know what to
do with B, a priori.
So you want to rewrite this
equation a little bit
differently in terms of the
amount of A that's used up.
So you define A, x is equal to
A0 minus A, this is the amount
of A that's used up.
This is what you started
out with, this is
what you're left with.
And so the difference is
what's being used up.
And dx/dt is minus dA/dt.
And by stoichiometry, what
you've used up, of A, is also
what you've used up of B.
Because for every A that
reacts, you have to use up one
mole of B. For every mole of A
that reacts, you use up one
mole of B. And so you also
have x to B0 minus B. So, you
can plug this in here.
And get a differential equation
which is purely in
terms of one variable,
which is x.
Right here, it looks like it's
in terms of two variables,
which makes it complicated.
By doing this change of
variables, you see that A and
B actually related.
Because of the reaction
stoichiometry.
So you can rewrite that as dx/dt
is equal to k times A0
minus x times B0 minus x.
And now you have a differential
equation in one
variable, which with some
tricks you can solve.
So we want to have the
integrated equation.
So we take an integral
of both sides.
We put in all the
x's on one side.
All the times on
the other side.
We'll go from x equals zero to
x, dx, A0 minus x times B0
minus x is equal to k
from zero to t dt.
And now you have to dig back
into the last time you took
integration calculus, which
for me was about
two centuries ago.
And figure out how to do
this integral here.
And the trick for doing
this integral is
to use partial fractions.
So you use partial fractions
to do this integral here.
Which means that if you take
this ratio, one over A0 minus
x times B0 minus x and rewrite
it as some number, n1 divided
by A0 minus x, plus some number
n2 divided by B0 minus
x, you solve for n1 and n2, and
you find that n1 here is
equal to one over B0 minus
A0 and n2 is minus one
over B0 minus A0.
And so you plug, now,
this in here.
And instead of having this
complicated denominator, you
have a sum of two integrals
that you know how to do.
Because they're basically
of the form one over x.
And in doing this, you also
realize that you have to be
careful because when A0 is equal
to B0, when you have the
same amount of A and B,
then things blow up
and you're in trouble.
So that's going to be
a special case.
So always look out for special
cases for these things.
So you assume, then, that B0
is not the same as A0.
And then you can go forward
with solving it.
So you integrate, and at the
end of the process, I'm not
going to go through it, it's
really complicated, you get
something that looks
like this.
A0 minus B0 log of A B0 over
A0 B. And you have your
equation here.
Now, we don't really have a good
way to plot it against
one variable.
And the usual thing is look
at specific cases.
And limiting cases.
And there's one limiting case
we already brought up.
Which is when you started with
the same amount of material.
What does it look like if you
have the same amount of
material to begin with?
So if you have A0 equal to B0,
you start out with the same
amount of stuff, but if you
start out with the same amount
of stuff, then this doesn't
look so different from, at
least mathematically, from
this one right here.
If you start out with A0 is
equal to B0, and for every
mole of A that you use up you
use a mole of B, then
throughout the whole reaction,
the concentration of A and the
concentration of B are
going to be the same.
So for the whole reaction, if
you started with this, A is
equal to B for all times.
That makes it easy.
Because now you can go back and
instead of writing A times
B, you can write A times A,
which is A squared, which is
what we had here.
And then you have the
whole thing solved.
So in that case here you just
have minus dA/dt is equal to k
A squared, and one over A is
equal to kt plus one over A0.
You don't even have to do any
math, you just look at it.
So that's one case.
Another case is if one of the
reactants is in much higher
concentration than the
other reactant.
And that's called flooding.
You basically flood the system
with one reactant.
And that's something that we'll
use again, hopefully by
the end of class today.
Let's say that we take, so this
is another limiting case.
Let's say we take A0 to be
much bigger than B0.
So we flood the system
with A0.
As a result, the concentration
of A doesn't change
very much in my pot.
It's hugely concentrated
in A, there's a
little bit of B around.
Again, with the process.
If I use all of the B up, the
difference in A is going to be
very small.
So at the end of the process,
I'm basically still going to
have A0 left in the pot.
So during the whole process,
during the whole time period,
I might as well assume that
A is equal to A0.
And that makes my life
much easier.
Because now if I write my
differential equation in terms
of B instead of A, so the rate
of destruction of B, k A times
B, instead of writing A here,
it's pretty much constant for
the whole time.
I'm just going to write A0.
So now, if k times A0 is a
constant, and this looks
awfully like a first
order reaction.
So I can solve for it.
And I get that, so I can just
write the answer because I've
done this already.
I don't have to do it again.
The concentration of B then goes
like B0 e to the minus k
prime t, that's the first
order reaction.
Where k prime here is this new
rate constant, this new
number, which is k, times A0.
So that's easy to solve also.
So always go to the limiting
cases, because
they tend to easy.
And if you were to go to the
full solution and put in this
limiting case, then you'd find
that you get the right answer
this way as well.
You can directly go to the easy
way of doing it, or you
can go through the whole process
of solving it and
putting the approximation
in there.
And do the cancellations
and get this.
But this is much easier.
Just writing the answer down
is always much easier.
So it's a pseudo first
order reaction.
We call this a pseudo first
So we're done with the
simple stuff now.
Any questions on first order
and second order reactions?
So the next step is, you've
got a reaction.
It could be a gas phase
reaction, it could be a
solution phase reaction.
There's some quantity, some
property, of the solution
that's going to change.
That's going to allow
you to follow it as
a function of time.
And that property could
be many things.
It could be spectroscopic.
It could be that there's an
absorption in the visible that
changes as the concentration
of one of
your reactants changes.
Or one of the products could
have an absorption band that
you could follow in time.
Or you could using infrared
spectroscopy to
follow it in time.
Or if you have a reaction in
the gas phase, and you have
more products or less products
than the reactants, and the
pressure is going to change
in time if you
have a finite volume.
So there's usually some quantity
that you can use to
follow the reaction in time
to extract out data.
And then from that data, that
you want to know what are the
kinetics of this reaction.
Because eventually
you're going to
try to find a mechanism.
You're going to try to find a
mechanism that's consistent
with the data.
So you get data.
Then you want extract out of the
rate constants and orders.
So let's assume that you've
found a way to get data.
And now you've got to
analyze your data.
And suppose that you've found a
way to measure the reactant
concentration as a
function of time.
And let's say that in the first
case, the simplest case
is that you have one reactant.
So you have one reactant, A.
So A goes to products.
And you've managed to extract
A as a function of time.
Well, the obvious thing to do
is to plot A versus time and
see what it fits like.
So you take A versus time,
and you plot it.
And you know that if you plot
log A versus time and it's a
straight line, well,
that's going to be
a first order process.
Plot log A versus time in a
straight line, you know that's
going to be first order.
If it doesn't go to a straight
line you know
it's not first order.
So then you go ahead and plot
one over A versus time.
And if it's a straight line,
you know it's second order.
And if it's not second order,
it's not a straight line.
It's not a straight line, you
look for some other order.
So that's one way to do it.
And you've got to have enough
points on your graph, because
if I were to plot a, let's say
this is my data point, if I
have a second order process, at
the beginning it's going to
look an awful lot like a
first order process.
It's not until after
a while that it's
going to start to deviate.
So you've got to have enough
points down in time to make
sure that you can differentiate
between a
straight line and a line
that's not straight.
And usually, that's often
a mistake that
experimentalists make.
They look at the beginning.
They say, oh, it's a straight
line, work is done.
Go home.
But usually you need to have a
good amount of the reactant
consumed before you can tell the
difference between first
and second order.
So you'll have an opportunity
to do this on the homework.
This kind of exercise of
extracting the order of a
simple reaction.
Another way to do it if you have
a simple reaction is to
look at half-lives.
That would be the half-life
method.
If you can measure A as a
function of time, then you
know when you've gotten
A over two.
So, you know that if I look at
the half-life versus the
concentration, the initial
concentration, of my reactant,
that tells me something
about the order.
Because we saw that for our
first order, t 1/2 was
independent of the initial
concentration.
And that for a second order, t
1/2 was proportional to one
over the inverse of the
initial concentration.
So if you plot t 1/2 versus A0,
or have a few A0 versus t
1/2s, then you can tell the
difference between first order
and a second order reaction,
and see which one fits.
Sometimes to get even more solid
numbers, because from
here you can also extract k.
If you have a bunch of points,
of t 1/2 versus A0, you can
extract k, the rate constant.
Not just the order,
but also the rate
constant out of this data.
You can use multiple lifetimes
if you have enough data.
Multiple lifetimes.
So you can define, you
can define a t 3/4.
Which is the amount of time it
takes for the concentration of
A to be 1/4 of what you
started out with.
So 3/4 is gone.
And then you can put that into
your first order rate law.
So when you have log of A over
A0 is equal to minus kt, you
get that t 3/4, we can solve
for t 3/4, and you get that
that's equal to two
log two, over k.
And then you can do the
same thing for a
second order process.
So this is first order.
You plug in t 3/4 and A is equal
to 1/4 A0, and you solve
for t 3/4 for a second
order process.
And you get that this is equal
to three over A0 times k.
So it's the same functional
form as these two.
But there's a pre-factor
that's different here.
So here there's a two
that comes in there.
And here there's there's a three
And so there's an obvious way to
tell, then, if you have the
t 1/2 and the t 3/4 signs.
Basically, you follow, instead
of having many reactions,
instead of having many
reactions to do, with
different A0's here you
can do one reaction.
If you do one reaction and you
watch the reactant go away,
and you time it.
When 1/2 of it is gone, that's
one time, then you keep going,
like 3/4 is gone, that's
another time.
Then you can take the ratio
of those two times.
Of t 3/4 versus t 1/2.
t 3/4 versus t 1/2.
And if it's a first order
process, the ratio
here is just two.
And if you take t 3/4 over t
1/2 and it's a second order
process, the ratio is three.
So with one experiment, then,
you can extract out the order.
You can't extract out,
well, you can extract
out the rate constant.
If you know the order then you
know which equation fits, and
you can extract out the
the rate constant,
with a big error bar.
You're always better off doing
many multiple lifetimes of
different A0's or many of
these just to get more
statistics in the result.
So this is the simple process.
And you always try, if you have
something complicated,
you always try to bring it
back to a one component
process by doing something
like flooding.
So if you have five different
reactants, if you make four of
them in very large quantities
and keep one of them in very
small quantities, then all the
four that are in large
quantities are basically
constant over the process.
And you basically are
looking at only one
reactant going away.
And then you can use these
methods to figure out what the
order is for that
one reactant.
So, questions about simple one
reactant sort of processes.
It's pretty straightforward.
So now, let's say we have more
complicated reactions.
There are two ways that
we can deal with that.
The first, I already mentioned,
which is the
flooding which we'll
get back to.
And another way is called,
so we have
some complicated reactions.
Complex reactions, with multiple
reactants, that's A
plus B plus C goes
to products.
And there could be some
stoichiometry in front of there.
So one of the ways to deal
with that is called the
initial rate method.
We want to find out orders
and rate constants.
Initial rate method.
So if I look at minus dA/dt,
one of the reactants or the
rate of the reaction near
time t equals zero.
That's the initial rate.
Right as the reaction starts.
I mix everything together and
I, just as after I mix it
together, I watch the process
of A disappearing or B
disappearing or C
disappearing.
And so in reality what I'm doing
is minus delta A / delta
t near t equals zero, where
delta t is a small interval.
So there's not much change in
delta A. Experimentally
that's what I do.
And that's pretty much,
essentially getting this
number out.
And we're going to call
that the initial rate.
And the initial rate is k, and
at the beginning I haven't
used up anything.
So all the initial
concentrations are there A0 to
the alpha, B0 to the beta,
C0 to the gamma.
Et cetera if you have
more reactants.
So you measure this.
You measure this R0, and then
you repeat the same process
with a new concentration of one
of those three reactants.
So with A0 prime, let's say.
And then you get a
new R0, R0 prime.
Then you take the ratios of
these R0 and R0 primes, R0
divided by R0 prime.
So R0 is k A0 to the alpha, B0
to the beta, C0 to the gamma,
then you have k A0 prime
to the alpha.
B0 to the beta, C0
to the gamma,
and the k's you disappear.
The B0's disappear.
The C0's disappear.
The only thing that we've
changed is the concentration
of A0 to begin with.
So the ratios of these initial
rates is the ratios of the
A0's to the alpha power, to
the order in terms of A0.
So if you're clever about your
choice of ratios, then you can
get alpha pretty easily.
So if you choose, so if you
now choose A0 prime to be
equal to 1/2 A0, then you
measure R0 over R0 prime.
And if you get one, then you
know that that alpha's zero.
Alpha has to be zero here.
Then you know alpha is zero,
that gives you the order.
It's a zero order reaction.
If you get that R0 over R0 prime
is square root of two,
or rather 1/2, then a square
root of two, square root of 2,
then you know that
alpha is 1/2.
And that's a half order.
We haven't seen any half order
reactions yet, but we will.
Those are indicative of a
complicated mechanisms.
But that's what you would get
out of this experiment.
If you get that it's equal to
two, if you get that this
ratio is equal to two, then you
know that alpha is equal
to one, et cetera.
So it's a pretty easy way
to get the order.
Then you repeat the
experiment.
Now instead of changing A0,
you keep A0 constant
and you change B0.
Or, you can use flooding or
isolation, which is the next
process to get the
other orders.
And eventually you get
the rate constant.
Once you have all the orders,
and you have R0, then you have
the rate constant.
OK, so that's one
way of doing it.
And a second way of
doing it is the
way we already mentioned.
To solve the second order
reaction in two components.
Which is to flood the
reaction with
everything except for one.
So this is called flooding
or isolation.
Basically, you isolate one
reactant and watch it.
You're trying to get
back to a system,
which is a simple system.
Which is a system
of one reaction.
So let's say you take A0 to be
much smaller than all the
other species.
You flood with B and C,
and you isolate A0.
And then your rate minus
dA/dt, it's going
to be A to the alpha.
And instead of B, well, during
that process B's going to say
pretty much constant.
Because it's hugely concentrated
in B. You can
replace B with B0.
You can replace C with C0.
So now you have an effective
constant, an effective rate
constant, and then you have a
process which is effectively,
or pseudo, one reactant.
Then you can use these methods
here, you can plot A versus
time, you can find path lines,
et cetera, to gather
the order for it.
Then you can get alpha
and k prime.
And if you can change
B0 and C0, then you
get k out of this.
So this is basically all fairly
straightforward, just
tedious experimentation to get
all these numbers out.
OK, any questions on this?
You'll get experience
on the homework.
There's likely to be a question
on the final where
you're given data and
asked to extract out
orders and rate constants.
So let's move on now.
So, so far we've looked at
first and second order
elementary processes, and we've
looked at taking data
and extracting out rate
and rate constant.
And the next step is to
build mechanisms.
So a mechanism is when you take
a complicated reaction,
like A plus B plus C goes to D
plus E. And you break it up
into elementary steps.
What's an elementary step?
An elementary step
is a step which
happens in a single reaction.
So I could hypothesize that
this complicated reaction
happens in three steps, where I
need to have a molecule of A
and a molecule of B collide with
each other to first form
an intermediate F. Then I want
a molecule of F plus a
molecule of B to collide to
form intermediate G plus a
product D. Then have the
intermediate G plus reactant C
collide together to form the
product E. So this set of
elementary steps, where at each
step you have a collision
of two or three molecules
together, three is not so
common but two is very common,
those elementary steps are
called the steps of
the mechanisms.
And these elementary steps you
can define something called
molecularity, which is the
number of species that you
need to collide with each
other in one of these
elementary steps.
So the molecularity here would
be two, you need two
molecules to react.
Here it's two, here it's two.
If I have an elementary step
which is a zero order in one
reactant, then the molecularity
would be one.
Or I could have A plus A, the
same molecules have to collide
with each other.
Molecularity would be two.
And the molecularity and
the order of the
reaction are connected.
So if you have something which
is a molecularity of one, then
it's going to be a first
order reaction.
One reactant is just sitting by
itself, falls apart, like
in radioactive decay.
Molecularity of one, that's
a first order of process.
If I need to have two molecules
come together, then
it's a second order process.
If I have to have three
molecules collide at the same
time together, molecularity of
three, then it's going to
depend on the concentration of
all three at the same time.
That's called a ternary
reaction, and those are really
quite rare.
Termolecular reactions,
you need to have your
concentrations very, very high
to statistically get an event
happening where all three
molecules collide together.
So three body reaction is hard
and anything higher than three
body is essentially
impossible.
So that limits your choices,
which is nice.
So that's the mechanism.
And so what we're going to do
next is go through some
mechanisms.
Some simple mechanisms and
build up the complexity.
Any questions about
mechanisms here?
What we're doing here is, we're
formulating a framework.
Where we can go back and look
at things that are more
complicated, like chain
reactions or explosions or
enzymatic reactions, and know
when to apply approximations
and et cetera.
So we basically, here,
are just laying
down the ground rules.
So let's go to our first example
of a mechanism, a more
complicated reaction.
And what we're going to do is
we're going to extract out
integrated rate laws out of
all these mechanisms.
And see what it looks like,
as a function of time.
So the first one we're
going to do is
called parallel reactions.
Simple mechanism.
In this case here I have one
reactant, and that reactant
has a choice.
You can think of it as a
radioactive decay, an atom
decaying in two different
channels.
So it can decay into B, or it
can decay into C. There are
two rate constants, k1 and k2.
So you can write it like this,
or you can write it as A goes
to B plus C. This is how you
would write a reaction.
And this is how you would
write your mechanism.
A goes to B and A goes to C.
Each elementary step, these
are the elementary steps and
this is the complex reaction,
each elementary step
is unimolecular.
It's a first order process.
So in all of these examples, the
first thing you do is you
write your rate law.
The rate at which A gets
created or destroyed.
And there are two paths.
It gets destroyed and into
B, with a rate which is
proportional to the
concentration of A, and it
gets destroyed into C,
proportional to the
concentration of A. So you write
down all the ways that A
can get destroyed.
There are two ways here.
Two channels.
This one happens to be fairly
easy to solve. k1 plus k2
times A, and you've
seen this before.
It's minus dA/dt as a constant
times A. That's
a first order process.
So you can just write
down the answer.
You don't need to do
any math here.
You recognize that we just
call this one k prime.
And that the rate is A as
a function of time.
This is A0 e to the minus
k1 plus k2 times t.
And everything you've learned
about plotting first order
processes et cetera, is
applicable here, where the
rate constant is the
sum of these two.
So that's for the reactant.
The products are also
interesting to plot as a
function of time, to see how
they are related to each other
in terms of their
concentrations.
So let me go through
this also.
When things get more complicated
we'll quickly go
and make approximations.
But for now, we can still
do everything exactly.
So you write down your rate law
for the product. dB/dt is
equal to k1 A. dC/dt is equal
to k2 times A. The formation
of B depends linearly on A.
The formation of C depends
linearly on A, because they're
both first order processes.
To make B and C. And
you integrate.
You integrate here from
zero to B, dB.
Is equal from zero
to t, A dt, k1.
A is a function of time.
And we've already
solved for that.
It's this exponential
up there.
So you plug in here A of time.
And you turn the crank and you
integrate, and it's an
exponential.
So it's not so hard
to integrate.
And you get that B is a function
of time is k1 times
A0 over k1 plus k2 times one
minus e to the minus k1 plus
k2 times the time.
Things are already starting
to get a little bit more
messy in the math.
And then to get C, you actually
don't need to do anything.
Because you notice that the only
difference between B and
C here is replacing
k2 with k1.
So don't worry about
doing any math.
Just write down the answer. k2
A0, you interchange k1 and k2
at every step.
One minus e to the minus k1
plus k2 times the time.
The only difference is up
here in the k2 term.
And those are your equations
for k1 and k2.
And what you find, is the ratio
of B to C is a constant.
If I divide B by C, everything
cancels out except for the k1
and the k2 here.
Is equal to k1 over k2.
And that is called the
branching ratio.
The branching ratio, because
there are two branches out of
the reactions.
And this gives you the ratio of
which one is more likely to
happen than the other one.
And so if k1 is much
bigger than k2, the
rate is per unit time.
The units of k1 are per second
or per minute or per hour.
So if this is big, if k1 is big,
then mostly you're going
from A to B, and only a little
bit of C is formed.
And the ratio of B and
C is always constant.
And so you can plot, then,
you can plot the result.
You can sketch out the result.
So you know that A is going to
come down exponentially.
Time on this axis here,
concentrations
on this axis here.
So this is A as a function
of time.
That's that equation up here,
in exponential decay.
And the quantity of A. And B and
C are going to come up in
time, also, with this
exponential format here.
B is going to saturate at this
ratio right here, k1 A0
divided by k1 plus k2.
C is going to saturate at
this quantity here.
So they're going to start
both at zero.
And B is eventually going to go
to k1 A0 over k1, plus k2.
And C, eventually, will go
to k2 A0 over k1 plus k2.
And this, and the ratio of these
two lines at every point
is k1 over k2.
So, a simple question, for
instance, that you might be of
the type that you might be asked
to look at is, suppose
that k1 is 1/10 of k2.
Which would you expect?
Would you expect to
have, let's see.
So C is in green here.
C, B. Or do you expect,
so A comes down.
B comes up.
C comes up like this, or do you
expect the last choice,
I'm going to put the last choice
here, so this is, let's
call this choice number one.
Choice number two.
Choice number three.
So k1, the rate k1 is
1/10 of the rate k2.
That tells you something about
the branching ratio.
So do you expect this one here
to be the right one?
How many people think this
is the right one?
What about this one here?
How many people think this
is the right one?
One person.
What about this one here?
So the branching ratio is
the ratio of the two.
It's 1/10.
So this is approximately, in
my sketch, poor sketch,
granted, but this is
approximately 10
times bigger than this.
So that's the ratio
that you'd expect.
And it's the right, here k1 is
the rate into B. It's slower
than the rate into C. So,
you got it right.
So for more complicated, we
have a more complicated
process, we're going to ask you
the same sort of stuff.
And it won't be as
straightforward.
Any questions on this
beginning here?
Next time we're going to finish
with the parallel first
and second order processes.
And hopefully we'll get done
with the complex reactions and
mechanisms and move
on to, I forgot
what's next on the list.
But some explosions or
chain reactions.